We can use traditional techniques,
what we are calling now circular design
to make natural dyes.
We've experimented with kola nuts,
we've experimented with roots.
What's also important
is you get like the old,
the young, and then the future together.
When I think about it in context
in Malawi in itself, we
do have different types
of traditional methods,
but I feel right now
things are not being passed
on as they should be.
That's what our work is about.
What I noticed, it's the
problems of skills transfer.
We started the cooperative of women
in a town called Makeni.
This is like the headquarter town
for tie-dye in Sierra Leone.
And I thought, where
best to start this work.
We are using it as a means
to teach the young people.
I think it's important really
just to bring it all back.
Let us remain circular,
you know what I mean?
If we're able to, get
communities involved,
it would not only unite
them as a community
but it also encourages
that circular process.
Yes, we've actually done
community cleanups as well,
we're working with the city council,
it's really always a
great idea and initiative.
- Yeah.
As the community, we are
supposed to be responsible
for the waste that we are
throwing out into our environment.
So how can you get the
community also to just change
the way of thinking about waste?